okay so the Turkish president wants us
to stop calling his country Turkey and
instead pronounce it properly which is
one because they don't want the
association with the Thanksgiving bird
and two because if you look up turkey in
the definition uh in the dictionary
you'll see that it's a stupid or silly
person or a big fail so again listen if
you're in charge of a country you want a
positive association with the brand but
two also I think if you make an effort
to call people what they want it makes a
big difference growing up people called
me Kevin a lot because Evan was a weird
name and you just kind of get used to it
if you have a weird name or the
pronunciation is a little off you just
get used to people calling you something
a little bit different and you stop
correcting them but for the people who
actually take the time to listen to care
to ask how you spell it to ask how you
pronounce it that person makes a big
difference that person gets remembered
that person stands out and so you could
be that person for others as well